Dancing with the Stars premiered
yesterday they really changed things
after you get a chance to catch the show
I didn't actually see the show but I saw
a couple of clips yeah it felt very
nostalgic going back to the beginning of
how the show started more so like
Strictly Come Dancing yeah just a little
bit more traditional which is very cool
obviously Christie Brinkley was actually
out of the composition competition
because of an injury I mean you're a
dancer how hard is it to kind of see
people go through that kind of stuff and
then really be knocked out you know you
work really hard and you get to that
point and then it's not up to you yeah
but her daughter was great yes I saw her
there supporting so yeah can we talk
about tonight I know this is your first
year on the show but both Simon and
Howie said this is one of the best
finales they've ever seen how's it feel
to be a part of it and to see that up
close in person it's amazing I said it
at the end of the show but I feel so
honored to be a part of it's not just a
television show it's like we get to be a
part of media that allows people to
express themselves in a way that helps
other people see themselves in that
expression so it's an incredible just
platform and show that encourages people
to be exactly who they are and to dream
big and know that anything is possible
and you can see exactly what's possible
because this show is so inclusive and
look what happens when we do that there
are so many walks of life and I have to
say the young people in particular how
do you choose you know I don't know
thank goodness America is voting because
I love everyone so much and they each
are so unique an individual and then
when you see them all together on the
stage it's like wow what an unbelievable
group of individuals who have who are
unique but share the same like goal in
life is to just you know spread honestly
goodness they're all good people too and
makes me so happy you know obviously it
is hard to choose out of this particular
crop of talent is there anyone tonight
that still surprised you where you're
like oh my gosh you are still that good
and you could win this oh my gosh
I mean pretty much everybody that's this
really
is and I've been in a part of other
finales this is the best finale I've
ever been a part of because everybody
has has a true shot and even you know
comedies not necessarily like from my
expertise but Ryan absolutely crushed it
tonight and that would probably have
been the one for me that was like oh
maybe he could away and I don't know but
like tonight he was amazing and so like
each each story each contestant had such
a an impact tonight a different kind of
impact absolutely quickly you're
performing tomorrow night a world
premiere of your song I mean you must be
jazzed we haven't heard some new music
from you in a minute
ten years a minute is 10 years it is but
you know it's it's important that for me
I just I do it for myself and I'm not so
worried about yeah just I think in the
past it was always about being the best
and even though this is a competition
show I think this is an amazing
opportunity to do it on this show
because this is where talent is
discovered and people get to do exactly
what they do best and they're they're
crafting themselves as an artist and so
this is the first time that I feel like
this is this is me coming out as an
artist rather than a performer
[Music]